Maggie Haberman,
you're you're reporting on on all of this
leading up to the bombshell
reporting that we just got
from Paula
in terms of how the president's team
may defend this
I don't think they quite know
how to defend
this, Poppy, from what we have heard.
You know,
they were,
as Kaitlan said,
very startled
by the existence of this tape.
This tape
was something that they learned existed
when this aide to Trump testified
the prosecutors
were already in possession of this tape.
They didn't
get it from the aide,
although it appears the aide had a copy
when it was subpoenaed later.
But this is and has been described
to us
this way by multiple sources
since you guys broke this incredible
piece of reporting many days ago
as a really problematic piece of evidence
for Trump.
Now, I think they're going to
stick to their line of,
you know,
he says things
he didn't mean it a certain way.
You know, I'm
sure that they can come up
with all kinds of explanations
for why he used the language he used.
But it's on tape.
And one of the things
that's really striking Poppy,
about this to me again, is
this is someone Donald Trump,
who is incredibly paranoid over
many decades about people taking notes
of what he says
and people taking notes
of what he's doing
And here he is
with people
because he also has a habit
of showing off
when he's in certain meetings
and trying to, you know,
sort of puff himself up.
And that
is what many people close to him
said to me
they thought he was doing in this tape.
And it's not as if he didn't know,
you know, tapes or audio
recordings were rolling.
He knew what he was doing
and he went ahead and just said this.
So, look,
we don't know whether this will be
part of a criminal complaint,
but there's every reason to assume
this would be
because it's been said to me
by several people
this is the most significant
piece of evidence that they know of that
the government has,
you know,
even the idea of the evidence
or the various pieces of evidence
that could end up in this indictment.
We haven't heard
from the Justice Department.
The prison former president
announced the indictment.
His legal team doesn't
have the indictment.
As far as we know. We don't either.
But get
it that
point the
idea of there seems to be between
tapes, between phones,
between obviously the the witnesses.
There's a lot to work with
for what they're putting together.
Yes, there is
there is a lot to work with.
And one of the things I think
we're looking for this morning,
if the Justice Department goes to a judge
and gets to release this
this indictment, the criminal complaint
against the former president.
What we're expecting to see
is what they call
a speaking indictment,
an indictment
that tells a narrative that really gives
a lot of the information
that they believe proves
why the former president,
the former president
should be
found guilty
of violating multiple,
multiple criminal laws.
And if they don't do that,
if this criminal
indictment, if this criminal information
that they put out
doesn't have those details at the start,
I think what it does
is it helps give the former president
certainly continue to have the field
to be able to mold
and drive
the narrative about what
this case is about.
He's already doing that.
He's already doing that. And the
fact is that the Justice
Department probably,
you know,
if they had done this the right way,
they would have they should have
had a judge already
sign off on releasing this last night
so that the public can see what it is
behind these charges now.
Here's the deal about this.
This tape,
it is possible
that they might not mention it
in the criminal complaint,
but but I would bet
that they at some point
when this goes to trial,
that they will present this
because it will be proof
even is that the fact that,
you know,
the former
president didn't do classified things.
Right.
What they want to prove
is that the former president knew
these things were national
defense information.
And one way you prove it is by saying
these things are classified.
And the president
the former president knew that.
And so you can bet
that this is going to be part
of the criminal case.
Paula, your lawyer, it's most apparent,
I think, to everyone
this could tie in to
the first charge
were willful retention
of defense information.
What I'm interested in
is your perspective on
if you could think this could
play into the latter
charges, especially obstruction
and false statements
and the timeline
because this is a recording from 20, 21.
So he's already out of office.
So what should we consider
around that until at least
we see the unsealed indictment?
It's a great question, Poppy.
Look, when when we broke this story
last week, it really change.
I know
my personal understanding
of this investigation, Katelyn, Caitlin,
Evan, our competition, Maggie
and I, we've all been reporting on this
for a really long time.
And it wasn't clear to me
that the former president
was absolutely going to be charged.
And if he was charged,
what they could possibly charge him
with beyond obstruction.
But once we got this recording,
it was so clear
that this was going to be a key
piece of evidence.
I didn't use a legal team
to tell me that.
It was pretty obvious because in here
he is admitting in his own words
this is a recording.
This is the one of the most
damning kinds of evidence
that a prosecutor
can have against someone.
He is admitting that
he willingly,
knowingly retained secret information.
He seems a little confused
about the classification level
of this alleged document.
But that is incredibly damning.
We also don't know where
this document is,
so I am sure that prosecutors
are working on that. Why?
If they have if they don't have it back,
why they don't have it back.
But then also the fact
that he's undercutting his own claim
of his power
to declassify stuff
at any point in this investigation.
They've argued that, again,
to prosecutors
that they didn't have to return something
because he had declassified it.
Well,
this completely undercuts
that and could potentially go
to obstruction.
But it will be interesting to see
we don't know at this point
how this recording
will factor into the indictment,
but it's clear it's
one of the most valuable
pieces of evidence.
And as we've reported
before, this really changed
our entire understanding
of this investigation.
The time. Right.
The place
and the kind of evidence
I mean, the time this goes all the way
back to the summer of 20, 21,
almost a year
before the search of Mar a Lago.
This is the kind of evidence
that they have.
Remember, he's at Bedminster.
Up until now,
we didn't
believe that
there were any classified documents
that had been found at Bedminster.
So this takes this into yet
another theater.
And then lastly,
I alluded to this,
the former president,
as someone who's very careful
not to email, not a text
that has really been an obstacle
in previous investigations.
They didn't have the kind of evidence
that they needed
to tie him to any alleged crimes.
And here really arguably
for probably one of the first times
they have this recording
and it is so incredibly damning.
So we're waiting to see if
and when the Justice Department
unsealed this indictment,
how this factors in.
But it will likely be a key
piece of evidence.
It's the strongest thing
we know from our reporting
that they have so far.
Thanks to your reporting.
Now, the American public,
everyone knows the president's own words
from allies to current
political opponents,
Republicans are largely coming
to Donald Trump's defense this morning.
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy,
for one, calling it a dark day
for the United States, saying on Twitter,
releasing a statement saying that
he stands with Donald Trump
against what
McCarthy calls a grave injustice
and also promising,
quote, House
Republicans
will hold this brazen
weaponization of power accountable
Now, campaign rival
Ron DeSantis,
he said something very similar,
tweeting this The weaponization
of federal law enforcement represents
a mortal threat to a free society.
Joining me now
for some more reaction to all of this
and the new reporting this morning,
former Trump White House Deputy Press
Secretary Sarah Matthews.
Sara, thank you so much for coming in.
And we just
got in more reaction and a statement
from an interview
of Mike Pence,
as we were just reporting on
Sarah was just talking
about in the last block.
I think we have a bit of this interview
that he gave with Hugh Hewitt
talking about what he wants to see
now, calling on the attorney general
to unseal the indictment.
Let's listen to this
Justice
Department, I
think, before the sun sets today.
The attorney general of the United States
should be standing
in front of the American
people, should unseal this indictment.
Should provide the American people
with all the facts
and information here
and the American people
to be able to judge for themselves
whether this is just the latest incident
of weaponization
and politicization
of the Justice Department
or if it's something different
or if it's something different.
What do you think of what
Pence is saying there?
I do think he's correct
that given the political sensitivities
of this
case,
transparency is going to be
of the utmost importance
for the court of public opinion,
because the people need to know
what is in this indictment
in order to make a judgment.
And that's why
I think that the Republicans
like Kevin McCarthy
or some of the other 20, 24
rivals for Trump,
that have rushed to
his defense
are doing it
a little prematurely
because we don't know
what's in the indictment right now.
And it could be really bad
for Donald Trump
or it could be a
nothing burger,
but if I had to guess my money is on that
this is a rock solid case,
I don't think that the special counsel
would have taken it
to the point of an indictment
if it weren't.
Look, and speaking about
potential premature reaction to
this indictment just this morning,
Paula Reid
and her and the team have reported this
transcript, quotes
from the transcript of a conversation
that Donald Trump
was having back in 20, 21
where he says, among other things,
he's got this document in hand.
We've talked about so much
that he could have classified it.
But now I can't, acknowledging
that he still had
this secret military document,
military information and saying see
see look at this.
When you hear that, Sara,
what do you think?
I think it completely undercuts
all of his excuses
that him and his team
have been putting out there.
They've kind of tried
to use everything under the sun.
They have said things like, well,
he declassified them in his mind
before he left. That's why he took them.
This just goes to show in this transcript
that he took these things
that he did not declassify.
He knew he could have
while he was president.
And then he showed them to people
who didn't have the proper clearance.